[Music]
this is the ramsay
show you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host george
campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today he's also the host of the
fine print podcast on ramsey networks be
sure you check it out so you know what
the fine print says baby
it's a free call here if you want to
talk about your relationships your
mental health your job your career your
money we talk about all of it right here
it's called the ramsay show we talk
about you right in front of you baby the
phone number is triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
henry's with us in chattanooga hey henry
welcome to the ramsay show
hello hi i've got a question
can you hear me yes sir
henry
henry i've got you i'm sorry that's okay
i had a question i had a question i
tried to make it quick would it be wiser
to try to pay my house off or would you
rather me buy another house as a rental
investment
i'd love for you to do both but in the
order of paying off your own home first
okay yeah okay it's what i did
what i do we teach people to avoid debt
and the shortest way between where you
are the shortest distance between where
you are in wealth is to get out of debt
and stay out of debt so i want you to
buy rental property once you pay cash
for it after you pay off your house yeah
and a lot of people they call us dave
and they've already got the investment
property and so we're not going to yell
at you we want you to get out of all of
the debt but if you haven't done it yet
the way to do it is pay off your own
mortgage first save up and pay cash for
the next one and guess what it's going
to take longer it's going to it could
take three four five six years to do
that but that patience is going to pay
dividends when you own all of the income
coming in from that property and henry
let me let me expand would you permit me
to expand on that just a second uh the
here's the thing i own a whole bunch of
rental property today and i've been in
the real estate business my whole life i
did it with debt and went broke later on
i've done it without debt and i get to
keep it all
and so that the 100 of the foreclosures
occur on a home with a mortgage we've
done research
so um
the thing that happens is this when
you're managing this is speaking as a
landlord that's done it for years when
you are managing a piece of rental
property that has zero debt
it changes several things you're gonna
do
number one the repairs that need to be
done are easy to do
number two the cash flow on the property
a hundred percent of the rent goes in
your account
you don't have to pay a payment right
and so it changes the cash flow returns
dramatically and here's the other thing
that's very weird
you are never
desperate for a tenant
so you wait to get the best possible
tenant you don't take somebody that's
got like three degrees of sketchy and
put them in there because you need to
make your payment
you're never desperate and so you don't
get into sketchy tenants you end up with
better tenants and let me tell you what
that transfers to fewer repairs and more
money
and so it is a slower way but it is it's
a peace filled way to own rental
property because you everything you just
when i'm writing a check to that heat
and air guy
i'm not sitting here going gosh i got to
make a payment i'm going all right let's
get the right thing for the heat and
there because i'm going to own this
house for 10 years i want to do the
right repair i don't want to patch it up
to get by i want to do the right repair
the right way at the right price i'm not
going to put you in my house
if if if i think you're sketchy just
because i need to make the payment i'll
wait on somebody that's not sketchy
non-sketchy renters are better i like
those and desperation is always going to
lead to some poor decision making yeah i
usually get stupid right after i get
desperate that's been the pattern of my
life the kissing cousin of stupid if i
get desperate if i get if i get freaked
out and terrorized you know a lot of
people did that around kobe they got
stupid because they got terrorized they
were freaked out they got fear they're
watching fair porn on the tv all day
long you're gonna die you're gonna die
you're going to die you're going to die
you're going to die you're going to die
and then they got in freak out mode and
they did some really stupid butt stuff
yeah but it was all based on your brain
shuts down the critical thinking
portions of your brain shut down when
you're afraid and desperate as a form of
afraid and so i you know anytime i feel
pinned against the wall i'm forced to do
this the number of times i've taken
calls on here on the air over 30 years
where somebody says you know dave i know
the car is 18
interest and i know i paid too much for
it
and i know i should not have bought this
car this much car but dave i was the
transmission broke and i had to get to
work i was
forced
to buy this car
and i'm like forced and then an
interesting language it sounds like
someone's got a gun to your back going
you better buy this car at 18 and that's
how it felt emotionally and your brain
shut down and allowed you to just go
over here and check about six stupid
boxes and call it smart yeah it happens
with cars all the time and real estate
is probably second there yeah i mean
anything we do around money or life for
that matter i mean i've seen people pick
out the wrong mate because they didn't
think they were going to get one and
they got desperate
and they took you know sketchy mate and
that's not a good idea it's worse than a
sketchy runner
that's true harder to get rid of too
much more expensive
brooke is in claremont florida hey
brooke what's up
hi how are you good
so my question is i have a 2021 honda
release
i actually just quit my job because i
couldn't take it anymore and honda's the
only one that can pay off my lease
i just don't know what to do obviously i
need a car i don't know if i should
finance something um through honda
because they'll give me my payoff if i
um have them buy it i'm kind of stuck i
don't know what the best thing to do is
wow how much is your car payment
it's 6.78
wow i can't breathe
and you quit your job so you have no
income
i do um i got a serving job actually so
i how old are you 23
uh i'm 24. 24. yeah
almost like i've done this before
um
wow
you got to be pretty scared right now
kiddo
i mean i have my boyfriend um you know
he's there for me we've been dating for
a while we just bought a house so
i just
know that my car
he just got a house
i mean we got it together i'm on the
deed but
it's his house yeah
not if you're on the deed it's not
well yeah this is our house yeah guess
so i guess you're in a partnership
with somebody you're not married to
okay
um
there's a lot here so what i want you to
do is go get a kbb jump online to kbb
and find out what this car is worth not
what the dealer says it's worth
and then i want you to find out from
honda what the early buyout on the lease
is the used car market has gone bonkers
and it's very possible you can get
enough out of this car if you sold it to
an individual to pay off the lease
okay that gets rid of the disastrous
mess that is called your car
your car deal honey is cray cray
it's over the top nuts
and it was exposed when you quit your
job but it was all really crazy before
you quit your job yeah what you're
making in payments right now you could
save up in a few months and get a better
car to get you around yeah go buy a
thousand dollar car with cash drive that
for a month then go buy two thousand
dollar car with cash drive that for a
month then go buy three thousand dollar
car with cash drive that for a month
then go buy a 5 000 car you're going to
be able to do that once you get working
again but you got to get to working and
you got to get rid of this payment
and i don't even want to start on you
about buying a house with somebody
you're not married to you have gotten
yourself into a mess they are also it
just remains to be seen so get married
please
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today
george i i feel a little bit like we
didn't have enough time to address all
of the things going on in that young
lady's life so i think three things
stuck out immediately in the call
and for the rest of you listening out
there here's what our advice would be
number one
never buy a house with someone you're
not married to
yes that can create a whole slew of
problems but like she was saying she's
on the deed and i don't know her
situation on the mortgage but if this
relationship doesn't work out this is a
nightmare and someone's getting kicked
out of their home
yeah and
they're also going to continue to own a
home that they no longer live in and
possibly be on the mortgage
and so basically what you formed in
legal terms is a general partnership and
you have no partnership documents
when you are married there's a whole
group of laws that surround your rights
protect you when you are
two single people buying a house
together you are forming a general
partnership and if you don't have
general partnership documents there is
nothing to dictate what happens
and so uh he beats the crap out of you
and starts doing cocaine kills your dog
and you run off into the distance you're
on a mortgage with him
and you own a house with him
and you can't do squat about it
you're stuck
maybe it's not as severe as that maybe
it's not as bizarre as that but you you
are stuck
so if you're gonna shack up one of you
by the house the other one be the one
that's gonna leave when this doesn't
work
okay and and you're free then and
they're free
but there's no mechanism like in a
divorce there's a mechanism that forces
what happens with the ownership of the
house the disillusionment of the assets
of the marital assets but there is no
mechanism for this unless you spend
you know twenty thousand dollars going
into civil court and legal fees to get
this disbanded so it's just a nightmare
it's also a relational nightmare it's
also a lot of other things that are dumb
but in addition to that you just set
yourself up in a financial credit and
legal
mess yeah okay number one number two
if you're upside down in a car you owe
more on it than it's worth and you have
a ridiculous car payment that you
shouldn't have bought and some life
event occurs that tells you that
the way you get out of a lease is
a lease has an early buyout that is
different than the total of all the
payments
okay you can't just add up all your
payments plus your residual value at the
end you call and get the early buyout
because that is in effect
it's like getting an early payoff on
your loan when you pay a loan off three
years early because you're selling it
you don't pay interest on all of those
three years and a lease doesn't
technically have interest but has cost
to capital built in and so they re it is
a reduced amount when you pay it off
early an early buyout so you need that
number it's your payoff figure and you
need what the car is worth
in today's weird world for the first
time in 30 years of doing this show you
might actually get more for the car than
the early buyout is because of how you
use car market because the inflated
prices on the cars and so in with hurdle
honda let's say that little honda sells
for i don't know 38 000 and the early
buyout is thirty six thousand dollars
then you could sell it to anyone for
thirty eight thousand dollars but you
have to give honda the thirty six
thousand dollars which is the early
buyout you put two in your pocket in
that case get you a better car if the
early buyout is thirty six thousand you
sell it for thirty four thousand you
gotta come up with two thousand to pay
the lease out so that the new buyer can
get a clear title you do not have to
sell it to honda yeah and you don't
wanna go one option from a frying pan
into a fire and go finance another car
if you're getting out of a mess you go
get a beater a garage sale car
that has a horrible color
and is mechanically reliable and you pay
750 for it at a garage sale and it's a
1974 ford okay but it drives perfectly
and you're not you're not going to keep
this car you're going to give it a name
and you're going to tell your
grandchildren what you used to do back
in the day back in 22 i drove a card it
was bird egg blue we called it old blue
you'll be telling your grandbabies this
someday and this is the kind of car you
need to buy when you're getting out of
this mess
number three
don't quit your job
unless you have another one lined up
yeah she's relying on the boyfriend at
this point now you're really trapped
they got honda around your neck you got
him around your neck you got a mortgage
around your neck
and you're gonna get in panic mode and
just like we were talking about before
we picked up the call with her as soon
as i get desperate i get stupid
so i want you listen unless you're being
harassed physically or asked to do
something criminal
i just couldn't take it anymore that's
not an you know you don't quit you suck
it up buttercup
and stick it out two more weeks
for your i can't take it anymore and go
get you another job doing something
before you just walk out cold yeah and
that's the power of the baby steps is
you have options when you follow these
steps and you're debt free you got the
emergency fund you can breathe and you
might be able to quit that job and step
into something else and ken coleman
talks about that all the time bringing
the boat close to the dock and having a
plan
it would take it would take 48 hours to
land another job in this world
and you and you're you're gonna
interview different while you still have
that job take some of your
vacation time and go interview
take it there too often go pto time
whatever it is and go interview go get
something else landed
um you know see you so
proverbs says he who is impulsive
exalts folly
folly
i have been impulsive and i have exalted
folly
what that means is a folly is a is the
verb of a fool in action
so when i am impulsive i am by
definition a fool in motion a fool in
motion i like that and so uh you know
impulsive is not
i i i just live free no that's just
immaturity
and whether you're 54 or whether you're
24.
and so i'm not picking on her i'm just
saying some of you listening out there
these are some life lessons you should
listen to this show because it's
entertaining thank you but you should
also walk away from the show every day
going i just learned something
i want to be less foolish and a little
more wise that's my hope less impulsive
yeah yeah a little more grown up i'm
gonna slow down just a little bit i'm
not impulsing a car i'm not impulsing a
house with a boyfriend i'm not gonna
quit my job because i had a bad day you
know little just calm your butt down
i mean really
this is this is this just i feel so sad
for her she's just got a mess on her
hands and i'm not picking on her y'all
um because i was a lot worse than her
when i was 24.
um a lot worse
that's not that's not the point the
point is if we're going to listen to
this stuff we need to get the what are
the nuanced lessons out of this rather
than just be aghast at how bad the
situation is all right gabriel is with
us in st louis hey gabriel what's up
hi dave and george thank you for taking
my call
sure what's up a question for both of
you we are in the middle of doing a
refinance on our mortgage to pay off our
credit card debt the tough shed and half
of a car
and we're now questioning it because our
mortgage balance is 216 000 with a 2.5
at 15
15-year rate
and the new mortgage would be 244 000
with the four percent interest rate for
15 years no we're trying to
should we do this should we know
you're going backwards
you're taking a higher interest rate to
finance a stake dinner that you put on
that credit card over 30 years
that's what i keep saying to my husband
and i'm like but this is not dave's
rules and plans and
i don't want to do it like that tells me
not to do it now let me just tell you
here has nothing to do with what dave
thinks okay
dave's rules don't matter the only
reason i would ever give you a guideline
is because it's what's good for you
it's not like dave ramsey needs you to
go do it a certain way what's good for
you what's going to cause you
to win
and so what's your household income
um our household income net is
98 184 a year on monthly it's
one hundred eighty how much do you owe
on your car
on our car we owe
right at fifty thousand fifty thousand
on one car
okay yeah all right okay go ahead and
your credit card
our credit cards um are thirteen
thousand seven hundred and thirty five
mm-hmm okay and
um what was the other debt
the mortgage
okay that's all you just had those two
in the mortgage okay cool so here's what
i would tell you to do for you
not for me and not because of my rules
what i tell you to do because of you
once you cut up your credit cards
get on a budget and sell this ridiculous
car
it's nuts it's two cray-cray cars in a
row of all their income this is the
cray-cray car hour
wow this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today this is the ramsey show in
the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage peyton and hayley are
with us hey guys how are you we're great
how are you better than i deserve
welcome where do you guys live we live
in san antonio all right welcome to
nashville how much debt have you paid
off we paid off 110
305 dollars in 21 months good for you
and your range of income during that
time range of income was 115 to 155
wow what do you all do for a living
i'm a seventh grade life science teacher
and i own my own scientific consulting
company all right and i'm a land
surveyor all right very good you're
making good money what kind of debt was
this 110 our mortgage
looking at weird people how old are you
guys 24 and 28. and they were paid for
house that hurts my brain in the best
way yeah baby touchdown what's this
house worth it's about 250 now wow
that's so fun you're so weird i love you
you're amazing we love you back this is
great this is amazing
all right so how do you pay off 110
doing that's 55 000 a year in two years
he you were on beans and rice that's
right we love budgets i love budgets he
went along with it
that's incredible i'm the spender by far
but i mean you guys have been tight this
is there was no room in this yeah we got
we got promotions we got side hustles um
i started doing some wedding
coordinating on the side as well i
worked a lot of overtime
and no nobody on this stage afraid of
work right now
you're getting it man i mean you were
getting it thank you this is beautiful
congratulations have you guys always had
this level of work ethic i think so i
think so we've both worked since we were
young wow are you financial peace babies
i got to hear the story of how you got
connected how did you get started to do
this so
my parents did fpu when i was a kid
and so i always put that
as something i'm gonna do in the future
and then never really thought of it
again we both heard of dave ramsey and
financial peace because we grew up in
church and everyone talks about dave
ramsey um but we didn't really do
do find it i guess we didn't really know
um all of the classes like we didn't
take them all um until
we were married and we took the
financial piece class together but this
all started uh really much before that
when we were dating
i was paying for grad school in cash
and
i got haley didn't just pay for grad
school she paid through undergrad by
herself as well and she took off took a
couple loans when she was a freshman and
then the rest of the way through
undergrad and grad school in cash
and so she kind of
looked at me whenever we were dating and
said hey you know you ought to look into
doing a budget
that's a nice way of saying it hey he
had all the other boxes checked so this
was the only one we had to talk about
yeah
did it feel like a threat at the time
like you ought to do it it was very
casually mentioned like me then you
ought to do a budget yeah you you know
you should look into doing this you
you've got a job now and
you know and it kind of clicked and i
was like oh wait a minute
this is the time that i'm supposed to be
doing that i just have to put it
together yeah this is the future that's
amazing and i had watched her she got
her school loans bill in the mail
um in grad school from undergrad and it
had about doubled to almost 30 thousand
and she
freaked out and paid all of it off in
about four
months she paid all those off so i was
like hey you know this should be uh a
priority so we made it intentional and
did it
from then on out and i had my own budget
until we got married and then we
combined how long you been married two
and a half years okay so right after you
got married you attacked those bought a
house and attacked it yeah we limited a
really cheap apartment for about nine
months it was rough saved up we put
about 40 percent down
um on the house and so then whenever we
got the mortgage first we just went a
gazelle attempts on it and this is a
series of intentional acts over a long
period of time people look at 24 and 28
year old and go well dave it was easy
for them no they started this stuff when
they were young they put a huge down
payment they stayed out of debt they got
out of debt quickly and this is what can
happen yeah paid for house at 24 and 28.
well moms and dads that's what can
happen you teach your kids to work and
and there's and remind them that they're
supposed to go through financial peace
university i mean it's just not because
it's financial peace but because it
teaches you how to live principles you
know it teaches you all the things that
you should have learned like in high
school or before you were an adult on
your own uh when we took that financial
peace class we signed up for it as soon
as we got back from our honeymoon
and we went in like thinking oh no like
we're those people who don't have debt
like we don't want to rub that in other
people's faces because a lot of people
are going to come here hurting
and we learned that there was a lot more
in financial peace university than just
get out of debt we learned a lot of good
stuff there
and in our two and a half years of
marriage we don't fight about money like
we never have because there's no need
when you're on the same page with
uh with money and and this class helps
you do that wow you're amazing i'm so
proud of you i bet your parents are
jumping up and down
they're pretty proud score score i love
it yeah this is great yeah when the
kiddos turn out and they don't live in
your basement we we parents like that
it's a cool thing yeah way to go you
guys way to go so well done who are your
biggest cheerleaders outside the two of
you we have a couple at church that we
just really love and adore and they're
they're doing the ramsey life too
they're kelly and bryant burnett
they're probably our biggest supporters
yes they are very good do people think
you're weird like your friends like wait
what are you showing off your house like
are you just rich like how do you have a
trust fund they do they do think we're
crazy but then they hear i'm a teacher
and he's a land surveyor and they're
like wait can we like sit down for
coffee like how do how does this work
ah there you go now they're interested
there you go well you're living your
life well that's why we also started uh
we're ramsay coordinators at our church
now too so
thank you
you'll be great coordinators what a
story to tell your class
and hold up that it can be done yeah you
know just fabulous just beautiful
beautiful beautiful beautiful well we've
got a copy of baby steps millionaires
for you because for sure you're going to
be one before we know it you guys are
man you're tracking you're amazing and
how ordinary people built extraordinary
wealth how you can too and you're you're
on track so also a copy total money
makeover you can give it to somebody in
your class or somebody trying to get to
go the class or somebody you just want
to help whatever stir up a holy ruckus
with that thing man that's what we do
around here so
good job you guys thank you and thanks
for leading the class too that's very
very nice it's good and you'll get a lot
of
a lot of satisfaction watching other
people straighten their lives out doing
it i have so congratulations to you very
very well done all right it's an
incredible power couple right here
seriously what 24 and 26 28 28 20 24 and
28 a paid for 250 000 home in san
antonio texas oh i know what i wanted to
ask you
before we count that down you said we
stayed in the cheap apartment tell me
about the cheap apartment
we did we our apartment that we rented
after marriage was about a hundred fifty
dollars a month
eight eight fifty oh sorry wow 850 a
month
150 would be really cheap yeah 850 is
cheap 850 was as cheap as we could we
signed the lease and then we told our
family
where we had signed the lease
and the neighborhood and the
neighborhood
yeah you always talk about the year of
the dumpster fire new year's when we
came back on new year's day from the
party there was literally a dumpster
fire in our apartment a real one not a
real one of 2020. we were like we should
have known after midnight that's the
scented candle for 2020 yeah oh my gosh
wow so it was uh but nobody got hurt it
was safe enough safe enough it was safe
enough yeah i mean we checked that
before we signed the lease
it was decently clean you didn't check
in with your family because they had a
cow yes
you lived there how long
six months six months six seven months
and saved up forty percent down payment
that's right that's that's what i'm
talking about sacrifice when you get
that because i i said cheap apartment i
want to know what it meant okay because
um well there you go well all right
peyton and hayley san antonio texas 110
000 paid off in 21 months house and
everything
115 to 155 count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream three two one we're
debt-free
[Music]
[Applause]
wow way to go you guys
absolutely incredible i've got a lot of
hope for this generation dave if i keep
meeting couples like that we're in good
shape yeah i just
i don't know how you can
not have hope when you sit in these
chairs and we get to meet people in
their 20s every week doing stuff like
this it's
there's an incredible generation coming
up here
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you for joining us america
the phone call is free and some say the
advice is worth exactly what you pay for
it the phone number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five george
campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host
over the last 30 years i've walked with
a lot of people that had a lot of stress
usually around the money subject but
there's all kinds of stress and anxiety
and loneliness out there
it was particularly ex
exasperated during the pandemic all
kinds of crazy in your family
people had lies told about you by
well-meaning people or not so
well-meaning people it's wild out there
there's so much hate and anger
the good news is dr john deloney
can show you how to change your future
his new book is called own your past
change your future
and dr d is rocking man his podcast is
exploding the new book is available for
pre-order right now i hope you deal with
all kinds of different trauma how to get
connected to a community that makes
friends and actually make friends as an
adult and the steps that you take to
change your thoughts your actions
it is possible to be well and you
deserve to be well
your mental health does matter
the book again is own your past change
your future it's on pre-sale right now
for twenty dollars
and with it you get a uh one month
of weekly therapy from the folks at
better health and of course you also get
the ebook and the audio book offer
twenty dollars it's a great deal our
question of the day comes from
blinds.com they have a 100 satisfaction
guarantee if you mismeasure you pick the
wrong color they'll remake your window
blinds for free you get free samples
free shipping new promos all the time
use the promo code ramsey to get the
best deal today's question comes from
steve in oklahoma he asks i'm 72 years
old and my wife is 70. we're both in
good health we have a combined
retirement and social security income of
about 140 000 a year we own our home
outright and have no debt we have about
a hundred thousand dollars in roth and
one million in traditional iras
our wonderful financial advisor is
recommending a distribution of no more
than four percent we're looking at about
five percent to enable us to travel
while we're able to what is your
recommendation on the maximum annual
distribution it's a great question and
they're in a good spot and so this makes
me feel better about saying
sure
40 000 versus 50 000 on the distribution
is what they're really asking right
on let's say the million dollars in
traditional iras that's going to be
taxable
this doesn't feel like a big portion of
the world if they've got
you know the 140 000
income
so if the money is invested in good
mutual funds
and it's making
you know average market returns of
eleven percent twelve percent
why can you only take out four percent
uh just fear i think is the main reason
people do it why would a financial
advisor say that
he gets more money is that how that
works possibly
or possibly he is uh a financial
planning lemming
you know what lemming is that's an
old-school word
these are small rats that run in herds
and follow each other over cliffs that
is the funniest way i've heard to
describe financial advisors and so if
meaning you go along with the crowd you
go along with the crowd you go along
with the crowd and you don't even ask
why you just go along with the crowd
and so you don't want to be sheeple
so here's the thing that is a standard
thing in financial planning four percent
because after inflation and after poor
rates of return on the portfolio you're
still gonna be okay at four percent but
by god five percent you're gonna sink it
you know which is completely asinine
this is ridiculous
they're going ultraviolet
steve you are smarter than your
financial advisor because you have more
money than he does
and you've done a better job than he has
so you can kind of tell him what to do
with your money be real comfortable
doing that and dude if you want to pull
out six percent it's okay with me i
think you're going to be okay if you
want to pull out 10 percent you're not
going to destroy the portfolio because
dude i mean you're 70. well you're going
to live too 170 you know you're not
going to wind this thing down in 25
years you're not gonna you're not going
to tear the principal up in 25 years
even doing that so you can be
in a position to enjoy your life and so
i would suggest five maybe six percent
draw down on this uh if you've got it
invested in good mutual funds that are
giving you market rates of return
um and i also would suggest that you're
wonderful that's what he called them
right wonderful yeah those are not my
words wonderful financial advisor have a
better have a good explanation for why
he's giving you these numbers
if you're getting an 11 or 12 rate of
return why are you suggesting that five
percent is going to destroy my life when
four percent does not
it's not logical one percent is not
life-changing either way well it's not
logical it's there's nothing it's only
based in that's a standard
card industry style
in the industry i am curious dave would
you say what's strategically the best
route to go using the roth portion first
versus traditional the traditional's got
a mandatory uh distribution distribution
anyway
um
you know the uh at 70 and a half that
he's going to have to begin and so i'm
going to start there and at least do the
mandatory
uh the roth is tax-free and will pass
tax-free
i'm probably going to use the
traditional
i'm probably gonna go and pay the taxes
on it and pull out enough to pay the
taxes on it before i touch the roth and
let the roth continue to grow tax free
because it will pass uh to your heirs
tax free as well
so that's that's the good news on that
good deal so good question
wyatt is with us in omaha nebraska hey
wyatt welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave how are you guys thank you for
taking my call sure what's up
um so i had some questions about i had a
question about some debt that my wife
and i have
we have about
thirty four thousand dollars in combined
debt mostly consisting of my student
loans and the remainder of my car loan
and a little bit of that is is the
minimal amount she owes on her car right
now
my student loans sit at about 9 000
remaining right now
my car loan is about 19 and her car is
about 6 000.
um our total household income is a
little over 100 000 a year
and we've been saving for the last year
and we have about 35 000 saved between
the two of us right now and none of that
no credit card debt no mortgage at the
moment um my question is whether i
should you know just bite the bullet and
pay off the remainder of my student
loans while there's zero percent
interest right now and then focus on the
car loan after that or if i should take
advantage of the car market right now
and possibly sell my car because the
kelly blue book value is about thirty
seven thousand four
well four
cars worth thirty seven and you owe
nineteen
yeah and you're clearly not in love with
the car
well you know i've been thinking about
um you know
how to get rid of some of my debt and it
seems like it could be a possibility to
so run the tell me the numbers again it
was 19 on the car and what all and what
else student loan was nine
nine thousand on my student loans my
screen is what i owe on the car and her
car is six thousand left six so 15
and you've got the cash to pay this all
off today just write a check dude be out
of debt
you see that's my thought um what are
you saving up for what's your deal
well so we want to buy a house well
you're broke man you can't buy how are
you gonna get out of that that's not
house money that's paying off debt money
right now
sure yeah of course write a check today
and be debt free and then get on
yourself on a budget and save up your
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses
and then start saving for your house
down payment you were able to save up 35
while making all these payments now
imagine all these payments are freed up
and you save up this 35 and it's going
to turn into 50 60 real fast
it's a good way to look at it you know i
i've recently started um you know
listening to you more often my wife's
listened to you for a couple years and
she read total money makeover and i've
started reading it right now and
you know it's just opened my eyes a
little bit um you know i think the good
thing is we don't have any credit card
debt you know we don't we don't use them
too often we only have one and that
doesn't change the answer though
yeah of course yeah yeah answer is when
you when you get off the loan or when
you get off the phone are you gonna get
out of debt
i i believe so all right and cut up the
cars while you're at it just for [ __ ]
cut them up get on a budget get on a
debit card fix your emergency fund up to
three to six months of expenses and then
let's get this thing moving and
uh get your house down payment safe dude
you're making a lot of money and you've
really done a pretty good job overall
the good news is you got this big old
savings account and you can just wipe it
out baby you can just send how long take
you get out of debt minute and a half
that's a good deal right there a minute
and a half you can buy that snowball in
a minute and a half you don't need the
credit card when you're debt-free making
100k you become the banker i like that
much better ding ding love it
wow well done well done
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's john deloney co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host george
campbell ramsey personality
is my co-host today as we answer your
questions about your relationships your
life your mental health your money your
work your career everything about you
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five john starts
off this hour in sunnyvale florida hi
john or california hey john how are you
hi dave hi george thank you so much for
taking my call sure what's up
uh so i want to contribute to my roth
ira through the backdoor roth ira method
but the problem is is that i currently
have funds in my traditional ira so if i
attempt to do a backdoor roth i would
trigger a pro rather rule
correct my job offers the opportunity of
rolling in the traditional ira funds to
my
work 401k which would then zero out my
traditional ira so then i can safely do
a backdoor roth would you recommend
doing that
you can also safely do a backdoor roth
if you reduce the traditional by
converting some of it to roth
and pay the taxes
right and
if the amount this must be a mammoth
this must be a mammoth traditional ira
how big is it
uh it's not youtube mammothy it's uh
it's at 61 000
right now
and that's triggering the the back door
roth is going to trigger a distribution
on that
uh that's what i i have done a back door
rothschild before
i know but it doesn't always trigger a
distribution on your traditional just if
the traditional meets some of the uh
mathematical guidelines if it's large
enough
oh i don't think that's large enough i
don't think that's large have you talked
have you talked to your smartvestor pro
about this
uh no i have not talked to my smartphone
regarding this okay yeah i think you
need to get a pro in your corner and
talk that through because typically if
we if the if the roth ira is going to
cause some kind of a distribution
problem it's because the ratio and i
can't i can't remember what the stupid
rules called off the top of my head but
there's a math rule that triggers this
and it's not all of them if you have a
tiny little
let's say you had a six thousand dollar
as an example uh traditional right it
wouldn't trigger it at all
100 could not okay
um i i just can't remember how to do the
calculation or what the name of the
stupid thing is off the top of my head
so you're going to sit down with
somebody knows more than i know but the
uh that does this every day but you're i
think you're okay i don't think you're
going to have to do this
and it could be that if you move
twenty thousand dollars of this over
into roth and that creates a three
thousand dollar four thousand tax bill
that you're not going to have any
problem that's possible too that that's
a a good way to do it but the trick is
get with your smart investor pro and get
somebody to get down in the weeds of
your numbers that um
that does this every day and i think
they can guide you through this you
could go the way you're suggesting but
it'd be my last option
yeah it's an interesting situation when
you get into the pro rata stuff and
really dive deep when it comes to moving
around your iras and your employers
retirement plans it can get messy so i
like having that pro in my corner i can
just go hey man i've got this what would
you do if you're in my shoes yeah that
helps
so there is a lot in the news about debt
these days oh yeah never gets old does
it you've been doing it 30 years long
time amazing i keep hearing there's debt
in the news wow well i found this
article earlier today dave and it was
interesting because i found some
conflicting news so maybe you can help
me sort this out here's one from fox
business which was encouraging more
americans optimistic about their
finances in 2022 despite inflation
so inflation's rising at the fastest
pace in decades it says which means
consumers are paying more for rent
utilities groceries than ever before
plus federal student loan payments
restart this year potentially impacting
financial stability of millions of
borrowers however a new survey from ally
bank shows that most americans are
optimistic about their finances despite
all of this
more than half 53 percent of respondents
said they're confident about their
personal financial standing 59 believe
they'll be better off financially a year
from now and two-thirds 65 said they'll
likely achieve their financial goals for
2022 even with record high inflation so
people
out there are optimistic and even with
the fact that they've gone further in
debt in 2021 than at any time in history
that's consumer
here's what we're seeing from uh reuters
here u.s household debt increased by one
trillion dollars in 2021 the most since
2007. higher borrowing was fueled in
part by rising prices as consumers cope
with strongest inflation seen in nearly
four decades and households supported by
increased savings and higher incomes
seem to be handling the larger debt
loads well so far
so far
so this brings me to my next point dave
i'm curious
so far you've seen some things in your
day uh not trying to age you here but
you you've been through 2008 you've been
through a real recession and this is
saying the debt has increased the most
since 07 right before our last big
recession
do you feel like we're heading towards
another one based on these numbers
well i don't know
i don't know the answer on that
economists and weather forecasters only
people can be wrong all the time keep
their jobs but um
but the uh uh uh
the thing that is is
that all that always does run parallel
with this okay is
if my income is high enough and i can
keep spending even money i don't have by
going further into debt then i can
ignore inflation and i can ignore the
fact that i'm going further in debt than
i ever have in my life and i can ignore
the fact that the united states of
america is going further in debt than it
has ever gone in
that the deficit has doubled in one
decade
doubled
the amount of debt we're in in the
united states has doubled the united
states government has doubled the debt
and that pulls money out of the economy
so when the u.s
borrows money using bonds
and parks it on the sidelines they
borrow
you know a trillion dollars here a
trillion dollars there and they park
that money over on the shelf
it's no longer out here moving around
doing things it's sitting over here
they're sidelining it they're
shrinking the money supply by sucking
the marrow out of the bones of the
economy with the borrowing for the
united states government that's what
they're doing then add to that the
consumer's doing the same stupid thing
only the consumer's stimulating the
economy because they're buying things in
the economy and that's cycling that
money cycling so when they spend money
on a car even if it's borrowed money
that car purchase goes into a car
company which goes into car company
salaries which goes back into the rest
that guy working at the car company on
the toyota line can go out and buy a
stake you know and which by the way
doubled too and so because they must
have universal wage and at the cattle
farm so uh you know wages are impacting
all of these prices left and right so
we're making more spending more
and
spending more due to inflation as well
and so what we've got here is we've got
a recipe for a comeuppance hmm it's a
good way to say it uh it sounds like
winnie the pooh yeah come up and a
comeuppance is coming it's an f it's a
heffalump it's a comeuppance is coming
ups are coming so we've got low interest
rates that's what's happening because
you know what you're doing is think
about this just on an individual level
all right think about your friend
who's borrowing himself into oblivion
he's going to get a car payment he's
going vacation on a credit card and you
can you can just watch him he's heading
to the wall he's going to hit the wall
he's going to hit the financial wall and
you can't stop him because he feels good
because he's making more money never
made in his life because he just got out
of college
and he got a big job
but he's spending more he's spending
like he's in congress and a comeuppance
is coming you know that on an individual
basis and that's what this says on a
macro basis wow so it doesn't matter how
you feel about finances what are you
going to do about it are you going to
rely on the economy to decide to dictate
your financial goals
not me please no
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over eight hundred dollars
a year go to puretalk.com and choose the
affordable plan that's right for you
with their 30-day risk-free guarantee
you have nothing to lose go to
puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
[Music]
[Applause]
well it's tax season
i don't know anybody loves that unless
you're an accountant that is the truth
is most of us dread filing taxes because
it makes us mad and it's a pain and it's
confusing and if tax filing taxes wasn't
bad enough tax software if you're using
that they hit you with extra fees or
they try to sell you debt they try to oh
god it's a mess
but filing your taxes does not have to
be horrible we created ramsey smart tax
to give you software that you can
actually trust
smart tax has steps that are simple and
clear so you know you've done your taxes
right
no more headaches and second guessing
yourself will never tack on a surprise
fee for you we won't sell your info to
scummy companies
uh we won't offer you debt can you
imagine that a ramsey product offering
you that yeah so when you sign up for
ramsey plus it's even easier if you're a
ramsey plus member you actually file
your federal taxes free with ramsey
smart tax so
don't get taken advantage of by your tax
software ever again start your free
trial of ramsey plus file your taxes
free at ramsey solutions dot com slash
ramsay plus
ramsay solutions
dot com
slash ramsay plus get in the free trial
do your taxes on ramsey smart tax for
free there's a lot of ramsey and all of
that we like to include that just make
sure you know where it's coming from for
sure pete is with us pizza in chicago
oops that's not good i can't get rid of
it can you help thank you
all right uh jeez why don't you pete is
in chicago i think peter you there
no still okay
one more time we got him we got him dave
has not been talking talk radio but for
30 years and he can't push the right
freaking bike makes me feel better pete
how are you
about your same age dave and i'm
electronically challenged also well
thanks you and i repair brother
we'll try to get through this together
george will help us mit today all right
what's going on here's my question uh
here's my question but i imagine it's
too late to do much
i was coming back through iowa
right before thanksgiving and my duramax
pickup truck broke down
went into a dealership
they put a part on it that was wrong i
end up spending a night in a hotel
i end up having to have someone come get
me i don't get this back until new
year's eve
and as this whole thing went on
they said we got to compensate you
somehow we got to compensate i'm working
with customer service for this company
and they want to give me 100 bucks
and i'm talking to them on my way to go
get the pickup truck and i said
something's got to be settled before i
pick it up or you won't do a darn thing
for me
they put parts on that i didn't
need because the computer told them to
any ideas what i can do dave
i'm not very happy
uh without your authorization
i mean that did you not have you didn't
have a discussion with them while the
repair was going on
well yeah the computer said this is the
part it needs
so i said what do i have a choice
and then well no now it was this part
the computer said it needed
and the computer was totally wrong they
called the engineers and the engineers
didn't know what was wrong with it the
technician found
the part on his own
and now you get a 6 800 repair bill
before i get paid for before i can drive
it out of there whoa
yeah
i had called uh
ford and dodge i emailed them and asked
if they wanted to trade me pickup trucks
i'd give them this one we could do a
commercial that brand had to pick up
they didn't know how to fit
man
this is a bad situation so you got so
the
service department not only did not i
mean you had no idea this bill was this
high
no i knew the first thousand dollar part
and then
uh
the parts that it took to finally fix
that they claimed was three thousand
dollars which the service department i
can't really complain them because they
did what the company computer told them
to do
you know they plugged it into the
computer as they do nowadays
and they the computer was telling them
what parts to put on
but then their own technician their own
technician also
figured out that it that was not what
was wrong with it that was other stuff
he found out eventually it was other
stuff when the engineers at the head
company couldn't figure it out they
threw their arms up
okay so why are they trying to charge
you for parts that did not need to
require the repair then
they should just take again i had to pay
i had to pay the bill before i could
drive it out of there oh so you've
already paid the bill
yeah that i went to get it new uh new
year's eve
yeah okay
they had it five weeks yeah um i guess
what i'm doing is i'm having a
discussion with dodge and i'm having a
discussion with the general manager of
the dealership
uh
well i don't want to say okay
i don't care what is it
yeah it was a chevy okay i'm sorry you
said duramax so talk so talk to chevy i
mean general motors has good regional
people to deal with
complete screw-ups like this
i worked with uh
lady in customer service the whole time
we talked every week yeah this is beyond
her though this is over her pay grade
because they're gonna need to write you
a check
so somebody's going to write me a check
for about half of this bill and refund
but it was not needed because i can get
i can put the tech on the uh on the
stand in court and the tech will tell me
what it took to fix the car and that
they've over charged me three thousand
dollars worth of parts that weren't
needed to fix the car and then they're
gonna lose the case
and by the way general motors nor does
this dealer want to be in court over
overcharging the consumer for this they
just messed up now what they need to do
is make it right
i i the dealership i got no problem with
them i think they went above and beyond
for me they did it i got a problem with
you they charged you 6800 for repair
that should have cost three thousand
dollars
the end result is they screwed you it's
their responsibility they knew it was
happening
and i'm talking to uh computers don't
run this place people run the place we
tell the computers what to do that's how
life works
so no i think the general manager and
you need to have a conversation you and
chevy regional not customer service need
to have a conversation and somebody
needs to talk about okay the computer
program the diagnostics are screwed up
and based on your computer program being
screwed up at the uh manufacturing level
manufacturer's level chevy's level
um then you need to you know you guys
did a wrong repair and you overcharged
me and you need to refund me for that
and i don't care if chevy writes the
check or the dealership writes to check
i suspect it'll be chevy because they'll
probably cover for the dealer because
the dealer was doing what chevy told
them to do
so
that's i guess is how it'll go down but
i got to tell you man truthfully
um
i'll be shocked if you don't get some
resolution if you lean in on it
and just make it a very simple thing the
repair should have been around three
thousand dollars based on what the tech
finally found out the tech and the
service bay were misled by a faulty
computer diagno by a faulty computer
diagnosis that's your all's fault it's
not mine i'm the consumer and you need
to make this right yeah and somebody
needs to write me a check back i
shouldn't be charged for these parts
that were not needed for the repair
that's not right and if you guys don't
make it right then we can make it right
by talking about it on the internet and
put it in you know going to court it's
all gonna be messy it's gonna be a lot
lesser than six thousand dollars for you
and then i'm going to have to sue you
for like a million because i'm pissed
and you know all this i don't want to do
all that and it's just not worth it it's
just you guys just because it's chevy
and you guys do the right thing because
i got to tell you what
generally speaking our work working with
people that have had problems over the
years ford
chevy toyota
nissan
they do a good job of doing the right
thing at the corporate level on this
type of situation
they really we don't we don't run into
them just messing people over they just
don't they number one they build a good
product um and number two uh they this
doesn't happen that much and so they
just they have
they've been making customers happy a
long time yeah and you're gonna have to
stand up for yourself financially
advocate for yourself be a little bit
bad cop i don't care they're not your
friends i don't care how nice they were
this is three thousand dollars that they
stole and i don't even care whose fault
it is it wasn't mine
it's one of you guys over here what are
you people messing with my truck i don't
know who it was some of y'all screwed up
and then you overcharge me just send in
and help me hostage yeah i'm going to
hire a new service where dave ramsey uh
fights it that would be fun
that'll be expensive yeah you're right
we can't afford that i'll do it also be
nasty and bloody and
ugly and no i'm not doing that okay that
was a good effort this is the ramsey
show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this
still on baby step number one
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit ch chministries.org budget don't
worry
it's worth it
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today here on the ramsey show
i'm dave ramsey in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt-free stage austin
and laura are with us hey guys how are
you fantastic dave welcome where do you
guys live about hours south of kansas
city missouri okay what town butler all
right welcome good to have you guys and
all the way down here to nashville to do
a debt-free scream how much have you
paid off paid off a hundred and forty
six thousand eight hundred eighty-five
dollars way to go and how long did that
take four years and nine months love it
and your range of income during that
time we started off around 92 000 got up
to about 101 and it ended around 95 000.
okay cool what do y'all do for a living
i'm a district operations specialist
with syngenta
i work in sales and marketing and i'm
also a ramsey solutions financial coach
oh wow very cool thanks what kind of
debt was the 147 our mortgage
look at the weird people
way to go you guys that's pretty
incredible how old are you i'm 31 i'm 32
in a paid for house wow what's this
house worth uh between 250 and 300 it's
a house shop and a little bit of land
man look at you guys
it's all yours it's all ours no payments
in the world
and you're 32 years old oh my gosh this
is we're seeing a trend here dave and
it's a good trend young people paying
off their homes you them yeah young
people paying off their homes this is
incredible so four years nine months you
guys really went for this thing what
what caused this journey to start four
years and nine months ago for you yeah
so it actually started a little bit
before that um i actually got on dave's
plan about eight or nine years ago kind
of had a wake-up moment um got on his
plan and i was able to pay off my
existing debt save up twelve thousand
dollars and pay for an engagement ring
before ever got married
and uh so i had a really good start
going into the marriage
yeah and i wasn't really familiar with
dave or the financial piece or anything
until austin came into my life but
was fortunate to get a good job didn't
have a whole lot of expenses had a
company vehicle and things
so was a little bit shocking to me at
first whenever three months before we
got married he made me start keeping
track of all expenses and teaching me
budgeting and whatnot he just just
sprung it on yeah yeah yeah
that's strong he didn't tell you ahead
of time that's part of the deal he went
to
this is the deal well and i joke that
there's actually five gospels for austin
matthew mark luke john and dave
my theme for life is if if dave says it
i do it plain and simple oh wow wow
that's dangerous
that's power i don't know if i can
handle yeah but we actually then did
take financial peace university right
after getting married and we've led a
couple courses so thank you i learned
the the process pretty quickly after we
got married he brought me along and now
you're teaching now you're teaching it
right exactly well i feel like we're
kind of the poster child for the house
buying process because it went through
fpr after we got married
we bought the house a year later we had
a really nice down payment we went on
the 15-year mortgage we planned to pay
it off early we set everything up to do
exactly like like you recommend so we
were very excited in that
um making that plan take place and it
went even better than we hoped wouldn't
even you know even better than we
anticipated by following your exact plan
and process and that was kind of our
guiding shift through the whole time so
we made that purchase happen and got
ready to pay it off early
yeah and i mean along the way every
single extra dollar that we got went
towards paying the house off we were
focused in on that's our goal we're
going to get it done we're going to get
it done early
just as quick as we possibly can so and
now you make 100k a year you don't have
any payments exactly you can do anything
yeah and i mean we had things that could
have set us back
our basement flooded within the first
year of living there
but we had the emergency fund we were
able to take care of everything and then
get right back on track on paying off
the house we had transmissions go we
actually bought vehicles with cash while
we're doing this we cashflowed two kids
burst so we were doing a lot
all at the same time when this all
happened and whenever i kind of factored
everything in whenever we bought the
house
i've been self-employed for vast
majority of the time so i had variable
income i was dealing with so i said okay
we're going to make the payment based on
your income what we know we can do
everything i can make we're going to
throw out an extra and so there was
months where we didn't have the thousand
dollars a month actually we really
wanted to put on and there was months
that we had some nice bonus or some nice
check so we could put another two
thousand dollars on it and just that ebb
and flow
really made us just focus
and say no to a lot of things but know
that's uh this is where we want to end
up being and we're going to do whatever
it takes to get there wow there's a lot
of intentionality rolling around in here
how much money do you guys put down
on the down payment we had about 40 down
wow just like the last debt free screen
i'm just seeing a trend here dave and
you said they planned a big down payment
with a 15-year fixed and they're sitting
here you know 28 or 30 years older
32 right
and they're this is the last yeah the
last two in a row and but it's um
so so you guys listening i mean this
what this means is you can do this
and you guys are just like you said
poster children and
and the the thing is this if you find a
a system that is proven
work the system
and that that's you know we can joke and
call it the gospel dave that's a little
bit that's pretty blasphemous right
there we may all get struck by lightning
but we can joke and say dave's rules we
can joking call george rules we can call
it whatever we want to call it none of
that really matters all that matters is
it's a proven you got to have a system
and you got to work the system and it's
a proven system so you don't need to fix
a system that's broke that's not broken
so you guys are incredible i'm so proud
of you she's kind of got a funny story
so whenever it came time where we were
actually going to pay off our house
austin came into the house and he says i
got something really crazy
that i want to just run by you
and so this last year we've had a lot of
things happen in our life that kind of
threw us off course and
honestly questioned if we're gonna be
able to get paid off in time or not
based upon where we're going and i was
driving down the road one day from our
farm
and and god just kind of put it on my
mind goes
you need to think about this debt payoff
we were on track to get it paid off in
about seven eight years
and all of a sudden i realized how much
our loan balance was and we had extra
money sitting in savings we had money we
actually started investing for some land
in the future and we had some money that
we had just been budgeting to pay off on
the mortgage from our normal jobs
and i factored all those numbers
together
and it came to within a hundred dollars
of the exact amount of our loan balance
so i came home i said honey you want to
pay off the mortgage tomorrow
and i think my eyebrows raised and i was
like you're crazy there's no way we
don't have the money to do this and then
just sitting down and doing the math is
like actually it is there we can do this
we can we just have to change the name
on the account from the land account to
the mortgage reduction exactly yep
wow wow
you guys are amazing
that's it and now you're free and now
you can just pile up cash like crazy and
go to the land and go do whatever you
want to do exactly that's our plan yeah
so good good job guys well done well
done well we've got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you uh you probably
already have a copy but we'll get you
another one because it's definitely the
next chapter and your story for sure
you're on the way to do that very young
very sharp very well done extremely well
done copy a total money makeover for you
to give away i'm sure you'll run into
somebody to do that and you guys are
incredible thank you so much for
everything you're doing and and uh
you're just an incredible example and
you brought the kiddos what are their
names and ages yes we have haley who is
three and reagan is one all right this
is the family tree that was changed by
mom and dad's courage
to decide to address the issue that
nobody likes to talk about in america
money
debt and now here they stand completely
debt-free house and everything you're
incredible austin and lara haley and
reagan 147 000 paid off house and
everything
four years and nine months making
92-101-95 count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three three two one
we're debt-free
[Applause]
yeah
look at that
those kiddos man that's awesome
beautiful thing absolutely awesome
so fun
it never gets old it does not get it but
i love that there was the decision
before the decision they pre-decided
that we're not going to do things this
way we're going to save up a giant down
payment we're gonna pay it off early
they decided all of that before they
ever went about paying off the home yeah
it wasn't like they woke up in trouble
and then had to go get themselves out of
trouble and then got out of debt every
step was intentional everybody every bit
of it from day one wow the power of this
the power of the stuff especially when
you start early and especially when you
pre-make the decision that's a good way
of saying that george very well done
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
america we're glad you're here michael
is with us michael's in knoxville hey
michael how are you
good dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
great well well thank you both for
taking my call today sure um my wife and
i are i'm hoping to keep the the keep it
going from the previous debt free screen
um my wife and i are considering paying
our mortgage off but we're thinking
about approaching that from a different
direction
um basically i would like to take money
out of my traditional ra to do that and
i know the typical answer to that is
is no but our situation is
maybe a little different
currently
uh milwaukee are both
about 40 years old
our house is worth about 575 thousand
dollars
we have a 253 dollar mortgage on it
and the payment is about sixteen hundred
dollars a month
now
combined
in the in combined we have about five
hundred and seventy five thousand
dollars in traditional iras
about 425 of that is mine
and about 150 of that is hers
okay
so why would you want to pay 35 or 40
percent interest on the money to pay off
your house
well
mostly because
it's there you want to pay 35 to 40
interest
to pay off your house
it would be it would be about uh
at our current tax rate with the penalty
we would be looking at about 80 grand
what's your income what's your household
income
150.
why do you want to pay
a 10 penalty plus your tax rate
to use your own money that's ridiculous
no
you really want to be out of debt bad no
i'm not going to tell you
dude well most of the calls
uh my office is a stay-at-home mom
so
it's been we've been a single income for
the last 10 years
you can't afford your mortgage payment
making 150k years i mean you make 150
thousand dollars we thought that we
can't
it's not that we can't i just
no i'm not recommending listen it is the
same thing as going to the bank and the
bank says we're good let's present you
pretend you're in a 25 tax bracket then
you have a 35 interest rate
and you go to the bank and you borrow
money at 35 interest to pay off your
house
that's effectively what you're doing
when you cash this out and you pay the
10 penalty plus your tax rate on your
own money to give this up you're giving
up money you don't have to give up
and no i would not do that
michael
what have you been investing out of your
income towards retirement how much what
percentage
all with my working life it probably
averages somewhere in the neighborhood
of now what are you putting right now
what percentage of your income are you
putting into retirement today
uh today we're on four five six so it's
it's right at fifteen percent okay all
right then just keep working four five
six is the answer i just didn't know if
you were investing twenty thirty forty
percent and not focus on the house yeah
and so that was my question to have that
much money at 40 in iras
he's doing great on that side yeah
you're doing great i would keep working
four five and six is exactly what i
would do and you're gonna you're gonna
whittle the house down and it's not
gonna take you as long as it feels like
emotionally right now that it's gonna
take you're going to get there and you
don't need to give up one third of your
dollars
in order to pay off your mortgage early
that is a bad trade i want you to pay
for your mortgage as bad as anybody in
the united states except you
you know and george is right after me i
mean we we we're cheering your own we
want you to we want your power for your
mortgage set a goal but we don't want
you for we want you to do we don't want
you to borrow money at 35 interest to
pay off your mortgage and when you pay a
10 penalty plus a 25 tax rate 35 of your
money goes to the government in order to
pull it out early that's the same thing
and i would not do that no no i would
not do that no no no no no no no no no
was he unclear i don't want to be
unclear i don't want to be unclear
please don't do that
because i got a feeling he's going to go
do it anyway yeah i don't think we
talked we didn't he's still he still
hasn't grasped the idea that was against
mathematically stupid this is those
convince against their will that's what
they say
vinney is with us in tampa
all right is it vinnie did i say that
correctly
yes dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
all right so i recently started working
on the baby steps and i'm almost at the
baby step two when i'm trying to play
pay off my personal loans and credit
cards
but here's the thing so
more than half of my income
goes into
paying off the minimum pay minimum
payments and then the
personal expenses and brands and stuff
you know
so i'm trying to pay off my debt as soon
as possible but it's like
the minimum payments are eating off my
income
so
i don't know i'm all confused now what's
your income
about
6 500 a month
okay and um
how much debt do you have
uh
40 000
around forty thousand
on what
on personal loans and credit card debt
okay no no car payment
no i'm my my i don't have a car with me
i've made it quarter recently so i don't
have it anymore and your take-home pay
is 6 500.
yes so you're taking home 78 000 a year
and you got 40 000 in debt there should
be some margin here
to attack this debt
so the question is where's all the money
going i'm i'm
i'm making the minimum payments that's
that's what eating up my
my
my income you know like i'm trying to
cut down my personal expenses but it's
it's just not happening
but your minimum payments aren't three
thousand dollars a month
are they
they are they are yeah you must have
short terms on this debt
yes exactly you got like a debt that's a
one year or a two-year debt or did you
get into payday lending or something or
what'd you get into here yeah around 2.5
years i was unemployed for a
while and
i had to take some personal loans
in yeah yeah you got a short term
okay
yeah all right so the good news is if
you pay the minimum payments you're
going to be done in two and a half years
with a lot of them
so anything extra you can put on there
is going to accelerate that
so you should be out of debt in under
two years
okay by just paying a little extra
beyond your minimum payments does that
sound right
yeah it makes sense but when i'm gonna
try to calculate my uh the debt and my
income
i'm i see that it's half of my entire
income for a current year so i'm i'm
trying to get that done in a year but
it's not happening so
it's so i just have to make those
minimum payments for two years and get
that now i'm
it's not the minimum payments it's more
than the minimum payments but your
minimum payments are so high
that they're not
um
that they are because they're on a short
term
and that's jamming it up and that's
forcing the payment size up to in order
to pay it off in two and a half years on
a regular amortization
so
yeah you're you're gonna pay the minimum
payments plus a little and that's gonna
get you out in under two and a half
years but you're probably not gonna make
it in one year
you could but you're really going to
have to tighten up expenses even further
than you figured out a way to do yet so
make sure you're doing a written budget
on every dollar
and make sure you've really analyzed how
much you're eating out really analyzed
how much you're spending on any kind of
luxury item of any kind and the other
thing you can do is look at picking up a
side hustle yeah there's only two ways
to create margin you're either going to
have to get more income or shave down
your expenses and i would do both if i
was in your shoes so i'm looking at
every side job i can take if you can do
overtime do that you're going to have to
sacrifice if you want to see this stuff
gone and on the budget side like dave
saying i'm going through every single
line item and i'm doing an audit can i
shave this down am i paying too much for
this i'm going to work on all my
insurance rates make sure i'm not
overpaying on premiums i'm going to cut
down eating out and once you do that
you're going to give yourself a raise
and find 500 magically in the couch
cushions of your budget
the other thing you can make sure of is
that make sure you have stopped
retirement temporarily
make sure you're not getting a tax
refund if you are that means that you
are having too much withheld and you
need to adjust your withholding so
you're bringing home even more
you just keep fine-tuning all of these
little things and i think you're going
to get there i think you're going to get
there faster than you feel like you're
going to get there
but i appreciate the call man thank you
for joining us
george campbell good hour good stuff
thank you well done good hour to the
booth people the booth folk doing great
work in there
getting her done
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world get your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
that is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host george
campbell ramsey personality host of the
fine print podcast on ramsey networks is
my co-host today as we answer your
questions about your relationships
mental health family
money jobs career it's all right here on
the ramsey show thank you for joining us
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five starting this
hour off is lauren in cleveland ohio hi
lauren how are you
hi i'm great how are you all doing
better than we deserve what's up
um i have a question about
um i've been working
recently for a temp agency
and around that same time
i got an offer for a permanent position
um so i accepted the permanent position
i've been doing that kind of part time
in the evenings after working with temp
job um but at the temp job and i'm
trying to keep this really clear but um
i i've been making 23 dollars an hour at
the temp agency
i'm 22 an hour at the permanent position
um today was supposed to be the last day
with the temp agency
um but it turns out that the person that
i was covering for is no longer able to
come back
um so they offered me twenty six dollars
per hour to try to keep me there
um
that being said i don't think that it
would be wise to do that because i'll i
know that with the permit position i'll
have pto i'll have benefits
it's also closer to home for me but i'm
also just kind of curious if there might
be a tactful way to go back to
my manager whoever at permanent job to
ask if i could get um more money
so you want to negotiate for the
full-time job and say hey they're
offering me 26. you guys are offering me
22 is there a way that we could get this
income up before i accept yeah no you've
already accepted the permanent right
yes oh well that's a difference what are
the hours on the permanent
um it's
monday through thursday
7 30 or 7 to four thirty and eight to
noon on friday
okay and so the temp position is at
night
um
it's kind of slips off right now i've
been doing the tenth
job from
7 00 to 3 30 and then when were you
going to convert
tomorrow oh okay and so now you've now
you're going to first thing is you're
going to walk in
if you keep the temp job you're going to
walk in and tell your permanent employer
you can't do the hours you told them you
were going to do
well i wasn't really even contemplating
accepting the
temp job
um oh i see you just you just now know
that the marketplace is allowing this
okay
yes
exactly um
no i think you made your deal
okay i think you're just going to work
tomorrow at the new place and um uh then
then but i would begin a conversation
with your supervisor
and just say hey i'm really motivated
right now buy money because i'm trying
to get out of debt and i'm trying to hit
some goals so would you please coach me
and tell me what i can do here to make
myself more valuable because i really
want to earn
i want to earn the right for you guys to
walk in and say hey you're worth more
money
yeah okay that's great instead of going
hey
i'm gonna blackmail you because these
people over here are gonna pay me 26.
oh man okay you know what i'm saying if
you go how can i think about it if the
rolls were reversed
and you had someone that was working for
you if they come in and say hey tell me
how i can be worth more so you're
willing to pay me more
yeah that's good instead of um i think i
can get 26 over at the temp could you
give me a raise
neither one or immoral statements
just one is way more persuasive than the
other and is more of a long-term play
because it indicates i want to add value
to this organization i don't want to
just be a taker i want to be a giver
very different spirits there one feels
like you're negotiating a craigslist
deal on a couch the other one feels like
oh this is a real person an employer and
this is a long-term relationship that i
value yeah that's a good point because
the craigslist on the couch is a good
metaphor for transactional yeah well the
other guy's giving me 26. so uh how do
we meet you know if you're gonna listen
i do my best over the years and i've
made the mistake a few times but not
many times to not hire someone who's
looking for an extra nickel
they're looking for an opportunity
they want to plug into this crusade they
want to plug into the wonderful
missional things that we're doing here
helping people and the money is just a
by-product and
you know many many many many times uh
you've had what five or six different
positions here yeah maybe more than that
and what you've done in each case is
you've earned the right to move into
another role to earn more money you
never came and said oh look at hey i'm
really talented look at talented george
you didn't do that although you're very
talented i appreciate that well i was
once a temp it's just like her so i i
feel what she's feeling going well at
this point in this stage of the game you
know the more money that really means a
lot to me but your attempt here how long
ago yeah that was a 2013. i was an
intern an attempt okay nine years ago so
there's your path that's the kind of
thing we're talking about here
and um
yeah and believe me he making 26 dollars
an hour i can just tell you that
back in the day i mean i look back and
at least
24.50 not kidding but for my first job
this was i was like oh my gosh someone
is willing to pay me full time to work
somewhere and so i was just so excited
you know your first big boy job and
salary and benefits like she's talking
about and over time you know if you've
got the right work ethic the skill set
the talent you're great to work with
growing you grow and mature and so i
think i think that's going to happen for
our friend lauren over here over time
how can i add value not what can i
extract
it's a whole different spirit
dean is in yakima washington hi dean how
are you
i'm sure i said that good afternoon good
i'm good what's up hey dave recently
found out that i have a small pension
from the teamsters
that i for a union job i worked back in
the late 80s
they're offering several different ways
to pay this out i don't think i can take
a lump sum on it
so my thought process was take the
larger money now
and then at 65 it drops quite a bit take
us faster right the faster you can get
better
lump sum is the fact that lump sum is
the fastest but they're not offering
that
no no and then what's the next fact nine
different options no good lord okay
so yeah just whichever way you get the
most money the fastest is the one you
want
yeah i'm thinking the it's it's like 360
a a
until i turn 65 and then after that it
drops to 67.
and that would you know that's that
gives me five years of of uh 367 a month
i can invest that in like a raw exactly
you drop that into a roth ira it roll
it's not a rollover but you just use
that money act like you never got it and
effectively what you're doing is moving
it systematically over a five year
period of time right
yes is that the biggest offer they're
giving you that's the big one that's the
big boy of the nine well
yeah that's a life
that's life only pension it takes the
wife out of the death benefit but i've
got i've got 500 000 life insurance on
me and thousands i want to get as much
fast as i can get it regardless of the
death benefit
fastest i can get it as much as i can
get as fast as i can get
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get 1 000 to 2500
off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we talk about your life
your money your relationships and your
work right here on the ramsey show we're
glad you're here emmy is with us emmy is
in birmingham hi emmy how are you
i'm fine how are you doing better than i
deserve what's up
well i'm calling because um i have a
question for you we have just started
your baby steps um we just got married
two years ago and we both have started
your course at some point and kind of
got a little bit off track and we want
to clean things up and get back on track
and i also in that time started a grad
school program i'm changing careers
to be a teacher and i'm in the classroom
at the same private school where i
started out but instead of an office job
i'm teaching so i am going to have a
summer job
and use that money to help with my grad
school tuition for the next year so i
don't take out another student loan but
my question is would it be better to put
that money toward our debt right now and
cash flow the rest or should i continue
to set that money aside like i'd planned
and hit our debt with everything else
coming in
i'm confused you're going to pay for
grad school in cash with either of these
two options
yes
okay then what is the difference you've
got you got you got debt
and you're trying to pay off grad school
and you've got you're going to have cash
to pay off grad or to pay for grad
school so no more dad and the two
options to do well are what then
either to cash flow throughout this next
year
and just use the money that comes in for
my summer job
to go ahead and pay off our debt right
now or do i
hold on to my summer money and use that
instead of cash flowing through this
next year
then where does the cash flow money go
i'm just into a savings account just to
pay off my semester each semester
through the rest of the program
okay but you're sure you're going to
cashflow the grad school no matter what
yes either way we are we are not doing
any more debt okay all right well job
one is no more debt so job one is grad
school with no debt after that job two
is get out of debt as fast as you can
okay
so that would sound like that's put the
summer job on the debt doesn't it
yes that's what i was kind of leaning
towards but i wanted to get your
blessing no i you know you don't need my
you don't need my blessing but i'm just
trying to help you think through it um
you know the yeah so the the point is
you can you can out of your household
income pay grad school out of your
pocket in the winter if you use the
summer money on your current debt
yes that's the fastest way yeah 60
yeah that moves you out of debt the
fastest possible way
yes that was what i was kind of thinking
might be a smarter option to get us out
quicker yeah the only thing is you just
risk if there's a bump in one of your a
problem with one of y'all's income it
could put you in a pinch on grad school
right that was what i was concerned
about and was thinking about was setting
it aside but i also want to get that
thing done and
i think it kind of sounds like from our
conversation though you feel like your
jobs are very stable
yes my husband's it's the school that we
went to and we've both been there for
years and so
we feel we feel good about it okay yeah
i i think we got a plan then yeah that's
simple
good stuff hey that's very smart that's
a very smart way of looking at it and
thinking about it and
you know the the trick is to they've
made the shift they flipped the switch
no more debt it's not once you do that
then you start to come up with other
ways of doing living and doing things
you get creative that's good we usually
say investing in yourself is the best
possible thing to do right now and you
can pay off the debt once you're
graduating but in this case she knows
she's gonna have the money to cash flow
it yep so we're okay using the other
money to pay down debt
how do you pronounce this d-e-d oh my
gosh okay
d deed
dead
deb
deb
oh it's a bee
okay that makes a whole lot more sense
i've never seen that now i'm just i i
was really struggling here i'm so
thankful you're dead hi deb how are you
dab not dad fantastic huge fan thanks
for taking my call sure what's up
looking for some advice my husband and i
are in baby step five
and
we have a 12 year old and my 12 year old
and i just finished reading
debt-free degree
he's on board
he kind of understands what we've all
been going through with the baby steps
and
i
we have shared custody so my son's
father also lives in the same town not
too far away
we all get along
and we had all talked about starting his
529
and
lo and behold my uncle
called me over christmas and gifted us
sixty thousand dollars towards
my son's five to nine
wow
that's incredible yeah
so
um
i don't know if i have a dilemma or not
i his father is not
the on the same financial program we are
he's more of the type of
he went to an ivy league school he came
out of school with 90 000 debt
um
so i don't know i'm hesitating to break
the news to him i would like for him
to also save money for our son's
future but i don't want to micromanage
this i don't know if i'm thinking about
it too hard but what's my best way to
break the news to his dad about this
huge gift
[Music]
well you you mentioned you guys have a
good relationship
you do okay
uh
how long you been divorced
seven years
okay
um
if you um
said something like
uh
uncle gave gave uh our kids 60 000 but
that doesn't relieve you or i
from the obligation to cover the rest
and continue to save
what would he say yeah
he would probably
agree with that okay
then game over right
i would say so okay you can't you can't
determine whether he actually goes and
saves or not
if this takes away his motivation to
save you can't control that yeah but you
have an integrity issue to tell him
number one but number two you're you're
asking and you admitted that and so you
know you're asking them how to couch
that in a way but that does sound like
you all have a very healthy relationship
congratulations because if a lot of exes
said that to their other ex they'd get
the finger right
yeah
you know so
and i'm not talking about the pinky but
i mean you know the the
the idea of you you can't tell me
anything what my obligation is you can
just talk to the judge about that but
that's not how it sounds like you can
say and go listen we've both agreed that
we're going to add to
our son's name
uh you know to johnny's uh college fund
and um the great news is that a lot of
the pressure is off of both of us but we
need to continue to
save because 60 is not enough
right
it's not enough by the way
so you're not done but but you a lot of
the pressure is off yeah and i think
having this hard conversation and it may
go the total other way and he's excited
about it and goes wow the pressure is
off and he doesn't relieve us of our
obligation but man does that help to
have that money growing for the next six
years until he's off to college
yeah right and just go you know it makes
me nervous that i might let you could do
this you could be you know turn it back
on yourself it makes me nervous that i
might let my foot off the gas and not
safe because this came in and i know you
won't
it's less accusatory yeah it's quite the
it's quite the encouragement rather than
the other and so so you know i just want
to let you know this and both of us are
going to stay on track we're both going
to keep saving and
because that's the kind of people we are
but man what a wonderful gift we got and
little johnny's just in a lot better
shape now and yeah i think if you couch
it that way unless this guy is
unreasonable or your
your connection has so many wounds that
he can't hear
clear encouraging statements
uh then but it sounds like you guys
could probably have that conversation
and i definitely i definitely know you
got to tell him
so the question is just how how to
build the sentence or the narrative
around it to where you still both of you
keep saving but remember this is good
news in my book oh it's amazing just
amazing what a great uncle that's cool
the proverbial rich uncle i want to be
that uncle that's really cool proverbial
rich uncle
[Music]
[Music]
this is a new segment on the ramsey show
it's bad news good news
it leads to a new another new segment or
another segment old segment we're going
to bring back called dave reads mean
tweets only this time i'm going to read
mean tweets about george whoa whoa i did
not agree to that
there's not a lot of so if you haven't
heard there is a problem for the
millennials
[Music]
george dave i've lost the millennial
weight loss program
the there's an avocado ban
on avocados coming in from mexico so
it's a healthy fat the um i know but the
i'm just saying millennial avocado toast
is
uh toast
uh un until we get our avocados back and
so well oh wait
it's been reversed that was friday they
on friday they lifted the ban
you're gonna make it george
you're gonna make it this is the best
news i've read in a long time because i
mean you had lost like a half a pound i
know he's getting dangerous you didn't
have a half a pound to lose no
so this is wild so mexico supplies about
80 percent of the avocados eat in the
united states there was a ban and it's
been lifted and it's stemming from
purported threats to a u.s inspector
in the latin american
country shook a bill so the cartel got
after a u.s inspector hanging out down
there gave him a little one up and he uh
he shuts down a billion dollars worth of
avocado toast buddy i'm just saying this
is this guy's this guy's got power i'm
in the wrong industry what's your son do
he's an avocado inspector but he
actually runs the entire economy of
mexico
a billion dollars worth of avocados
so uh yeah of course during the ban you
thought getting out of debt was the mean
tweet the mean tweets thing is coming
back during the ban
kimberly and i won't read your last name
because i don't want people to come
after that's not the spirit here she
might be 12 you never know
um she might be 82 and in either case
would we want people to
you know like bother kimberly that's
right she says i bet you dave ramsey is
super stoked about the avocado import
band he's like these millennials can't
waste their millions on avocado toast
anymore there you go see i knew it was
coming i don't know how i got hooked up
with that because i don't remember me
saying that one i don't think there's
another financial guy out there
in the space and i can't i think it
might have been david bach i don't
remember but we've all always used
examples that say okay if you cut your
spending
by just a little bit and invest that you
will end up with money we've said that
long before millennials were born we
said that and one example was always you
know if you cut out a cup of coffee if
you quit buying coffee and then it
became starbucks five bucks right now
it's with inflation's eight bucks but um
and then with the latte it's 26 bucks
it's insane and with universal um
life wage of 42 an hour it's now 42. and
if you uber it and have it brought in by
uber eats with the up charges it's 62.
this is getting out yeah i'm just saying
but anyway that a cup of coffee you know
if you just said i'm not going to spend
that instead i'm going to let that money
accumulate into an investment turns into
money it's a math example it's not an
actual suggestion that says you become
wealthy by not drinking coffee or not
eating millennials took it but somebody
said
the millennials were you know back when
we first started everybody started
griping about millennials the millennial
hate thing started right like they're
they're useless their get participation
trophies they live in their mother's
basement you know all that stuff they've
said about millennials which is not true
by the way but it was a and and some
some body in the financial world it
really wasn't me i don't think if you
can find the tweet out there send it to
me if i did it i'll own it because i've
said some stupid butt stuff but do you
think i said it james no i think it just
was a meme going around that no somebody
picked it up off of me there was
actually a guy said it i'm positive and
then it turned into a meme and then it
turned into i said it got conflated with
you yeah i i i tell people to live on
less than they make i tell them not to
do foolish spending and this guy's point
was the millennials would be okay if
they could spend their money on avocado
toast and put their money in a roth ira
and that's you know absolutely not true
that doesn't work mathematically but
it's an example it's a metaphor for
control your spending but uh but then
the millennials get all jacked up and
entitled and they're like man they may
have a kind of toast you know well now
they buy it to spite you that's what
they do well i i actually like it people
are hate buying i never had avocado
toast until this whole thing got pinned
on me it's delicious and i actually
order it now so but i can afford it so
new headline dave ramsey orders avocado
toast that's that's shocking that's it
can you cover it with gravy that's what
i want to know but yeah okay
red eye gravy baby all right uh so i bet
you dave ramsey's super stoked about the
avocado import ban he's like ha ha
these millennials can't waste their
millions on avocado toast anymore wow so
that's again that's the whole story of
me getting pinned with this thing um i
love the assumption that these
millennials have millions that they're
just i guess
collectively they're spending millions
maybe yeah
but we do love our avocados don't take
those away so here's the thing the mean
tweets we used to have to kind of when
twitter was young
it was actually a conversation
now it's just a bunch of trolls it's
just it's deteriorated it's just a
you know it's a paw trolls it's a troll
pile and so but the uh um so finding
mean tweets in the old days it was one
out of
five hundred tweets or something but you
could do a search the majority do a
search on dave ramsey you could find me
in tweets all you gotta do is open up
now it's not hard at all
boomer you know you get anything in or
every possible name that you can call
people uh yeah so
james if we're gonna do mean tweets they
cannot we we can't violate the fcc rules
on word said
on the air so we can't use a lot of them
we'll just have to bleep them we can
bleep them and they have to be creative
and funny and fun not just like oh man
it's not just hateful not just angry
basically he wants you to be creatively
mean if you're going to be mean do it if
you want to make a show with your mean
tweet
you need to be
mean without unbelievable cuss words
because we can't use them that's true
we're actually on public radio we'll get
fined the funniest ones were from the
kids in class that were taking they were
they were forced to go through the
curriculum yeah you know because 48 of
the classes are teaching our curriculum
in high schools now 48 of high schools
are teaching it so yeah they're making
fun of dave ramsey i'm going to watch
these videos the coach i wish the coach
should actually do his job and teach and
now he's a coach he's not a teacher and
now you've passed it on to me i hosted
our latest curriculum so now i get the
haters you get you can hate me i have
kids saying this guy's a tool really
yeah you're a tool i i guess i don't
know i don't even know what a tool is
but hey it's an avocado tool avocado
tool i'll take that but the kids these
days they're called a toast eating they
think they're just
posting into the abyss they don't know
that we can see it especially when they
direct message you right that's a whole
different ball game well here's the
thing the problem yeah it's just the
problem with this i think i think we're
gonna see a change in this um i think
it's in the air
because it's gotten so far out of
control um
and the problem with this is that and we
kept trying to tell people this in the
early days with social media when it
first started especially twitter
and it's going to come back to bite you
because this stuff is forever
even if you delete the tweet somebody
could have screenshotted it oh yeah even
if you delete the instagram comment
somebody could have screenshotted it
and so um
i'm up to like i think i blocked 10
thousand people that's impressive it was
a hobby for a while yeah you gotta i
would kind of drink my morning coffee i
blocked ten a morning you know that's
good and it's like pace yourself well if
you're gonna cuss me and you know all
those other stuff you know but i well
now it's a it's a medal of honor i don't
know if you know that but people are
excited to get blocked by you and they
hold it up as a badge really it's a
thing they brag about it to their
friends oh man it's a real thing who
knew i could create a different kind of
um
it's the only competition they can win
so they like to hold that up
sorry is that too i'm sorry i take it
back that was good take it back zing
it's a sport this is a trophy you
actually earned
a block by dave trophy
it's you can't mount it on the wall but
it's great dinner time conversation
wow well i mean
moms and dads um that raised kids that
say things on the internet that they
would never have the
backbone to say in person
um
because you get your face punched in if
you said this to someone's face yeah you
know and so you know it's and i watch
them you know they're talking about some
quarterback or
some vaccinated thing on some
quarterback or whatever they're wearing
out aaron rodgers they're wearing out
whoever
and you know
as
if you stood in that guy's presence he's
the size of not aaron rodgers but i mean
you know sure he'd have one of his
linemen pound you into the ground like
avocado toast i mean there it is we got
a full circle we can't walk around all
right mean tweets coming up not this
segment but soon james is going to try
to collect ones that are actually funny
james might write some be careful
james be careful he could get the booth
people don't get them
the booth
to get back at me for calling them booth
folks
is coming they come up in no idea what's
coming on the internet now
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today romans 16 19
everyone has heard about your obedience
so i rejoice because of you but i want
you to be wise about what is good and
innocent about what is evil
margaret thatcher said don't follow the
crowd let the crowd follow you that's a
little bit of what we were just talking
about and don't don't let the mob
run things
and i'm not talking about organized
crime here all right so have you ever
made a dumb decision with zeros on the
end because you didn't do your research
yum me too
most people make choices based on
feelings or opinions especially when
buying a house
in this market that's crazy check your
facts find out what you can actually
afford research what is trending at home
prices get an agent that's a pro in your
corner it's crazy out there
this is not the time
this is not the time
for amateur hour
if you're a buyer among a bazillion
buyers you need help if you're a seller
trying to
get the best possible price through a
bazillion buyers you need some help go
to ramseysolutions.com agent
you can find an endorsed local provider
an elp that is ramsey trusted to help
you with all of your real estate needs
sids in memphis hi sid how are you
hey dave huge fan uh
how are you doing great man how can we
help
yeah um so me and my fiance are in a
little rut um
she got in an accident back uh
right before christmas of last year
um
and it was during the time where i was
also out of work with kovid i was out of
work for about uh
six weeks
and uh she ended up getting in an
accident
they determined her 50 50 at fault
then
carl was totaled out she still had a
lien on the car for sixteen thousand
dollars should i have insurance
uh she was currently in between
insurances uh she was switching over
from i think she was with progressive
and she got a better rate why did she
cancel why did she cancel one before she
got the other in place
well she didn't cancel she was switching
them over but before they switched her
over they said that she had some
some 200
fee
uh before she could switch over but it
made no sense to us because she went
ahead and paid six months in advance
uh and i i don't understand where the
two hundred dollars came from
uh every time i tried to contact them
uh before the accident i had asked i
said where is this 200 coming from they
said well we'll transfer you over to
someone that may help be able to help
you and it just disconnected the line
uh why don't you just cancel the
insurance and go buy some i mean you
don't need to be running around that car
insurance so what how much does she owe
on this direct wreck
the wreck uh she was uh like i said it
was 50 50 at fault she still had 16 000
left to pay on her car
and
they towed it to
wrecker
and they were holding on to it in the
meantime
from what the report said
it seemed like the other person was at
fault because they turned on a green
with no protected turn
and she was going straight she turned
out in front of my fiance and they said
no she's 50 50 at fault we're not going
to cover anything on her car
so that that entire ordeal took about
another month and a half and
you know just going back and forth with
them and in that month and a half
storage fees are crude
um
the payments still do on the car the
storage fees went up to around uh
2500
on top of what uh what was owed on the
car i was out
for
uh like i said six weeks with covid so i
had to start dipping into savings just
to make ends meet
and
uh
she's in the process
of filing for bankruptcy oh crap no whoa
whoa whoa
you don't file bankruptcy on sixteen
thousand dollars
uh-huh
no
has she signed the papers
no no don't sign them
that's absurd
absolutely not is she working
she only brings in about uh
950 to a thousand dollars a month why
uh that's just what they pay her right
now why i told her why does she stay
there that sucks
yeah uh
i i have no idea i guess she's just
gotten so used to being there i don't
know
i told her she's need to she needs to
leave
and get something how old are you guys
i'm 25 she is 24. when are you getting
married uh we've pushed it back we had
it set for next year winner of next year
but we're pushing it back because of
this whole situation
yeah what do you make
i make about 3 000 a month i work in
construction okay
all right and we also have two kids
together we have a six-year-old and a uh
and a three-year-old i'm sorry a
five-year-old you need to call you need
to call a pastor and go get married this
weekend
you're completely married you have kids
you're living together you're doing
everything else and the fact that you're
not married just silly
you need to get you need to you know
that you're pushing this back and saving
up for a wedding it's just dumb on a
rock i mean you need to get your go
ahead and get this done all right and
this is killing y'all and uh uh hum and
so you got a big daycare bill
uh yes yes okay
all right so
she's gonna she needs to change careers
and you need to pick up an extra job and
then you still need to start negotiating
a settlement with the storage guy and
with the car
and get rid of the car get the car gone
get start working with the bank and
settle with them you can probably settle
this for
you know probably sell a storage bill
for a quarter of what he's asking and
probably settle the car deal for a
quarter what they're asking because you
know you don't have any money and
they're about to repo the car tell them
to get the car repo and get it sold and
get off his lot
or tell him to get rid of it i don't
care somebody needs to get rid of it
here's the thing everything you
described in this whole story
everything happened to you all because
you were passive and stood around and
watched it all happen
right
you stood back and expected this to like
the calvary was going to come and fix
this for you you got to get game on here
man
game on
like get this mess cleaned up yesterday
get some new jobs get some new income
coming in yeah get this car done get on
get on the phone with the storage guy
and go look what do we do to get rid of
this car i don't know how to do it but
i'm done and i'm not paying you two
thousand dollars i'll work with you but
i don't have any money i'm a poor
construction worker with a couple of
kids and i ain't getting money so good
luck collecting that no we're not
following bankruptcy on sixteen thousand
dollars
you guys are in this mess because you've
been passive and watched all this stuff
happen to you and you need to get like
in
engagement mode on every one of these
issues first you were passive and stood
around watch the insurance run out which
caused the whole mess and waiting on
somebody over 200 and then you got hung
up on and instead of just firing their
butt and going and getting a new
insurance guy you're going well i got
hung up on so now she doesn't have
insurance you got to go get insurance
right now every every minute that you go
without car insurance you're asking to
get in this kind of a mess but now
you're there so every minute you don't
deal with a storage guy every minute you
don't deal with this car company and
every minute you don't go see the pastor
and get married and every minute she
stays in this stupid but horrible job
that she's got is ridiculous
she's making nothing in a culture where
freaking targets pay in 20 an hour
twenty dollars an hour go work at target
go work at walmart they're paying
fifteen dollars an hour a whole lot more
than she's making yeah there's a lot
going on here sid but what i'm hearing
overall we need to be proactive instead
of reactive you guys are letting life
happen to you letting murphy just take
over you got to own your life get a fire
under your butts get those jobs get this
debt cleaned up and realize bankruptcy
is not the answer this is not the fix
that you think it's going to be
please don't file bankruptcy
and if she needs some encouragement have
her listen to the fine print episode
eight is bankruptcy a quick fix for
struggling americans i think that will
get her to step away from this ledge
yeah and and well you know you're you're
not bankrupt you're broke there's a
difference and you don't you don't
you're not making any money and you're
not aggressively handling stephen covey
in his book the seven habits of highly
effective people
says the number one habit of people who
are highly effective number one of the
seven is they're proactive
they happen to things things don't
happen to them
and so everybody gets victimized by
something different times in our lives
everyone has stuff happen to them that
happens all the time but living that way
is a pattern
is going to cause you nothing but stress
and pain
and so you're going to have to switch
the script on this write a new story as
john deloney says
hang on we're going to send you a copy
of ken coleman's book from paycheck to
purpose for her to read because she
needs a new job and you need an extra
job some more overtime so you're making
more money
construction's booming right now that
puts this hour of the ramsey show in the
books we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
prince of peace christ jesus
hey it's rachel cruz co-host on the
ramsay show if you want to do your
debt-free stream live on the show visit
ramsaysolutions.com
debt free screen we'd love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
story that's ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
you